it's been a 20 years since Will Smith
mated this look good he was on the set
as Agent J himself used his dance moves
to defend the galaxy in the music video
for men in black not hot but I don't
know about me it must be me what you
thinking sure you couldn't see this is
like the best video in the history of
videos for those who have a good news
stone hero in the song was featured on
the movie soundtrack and in Smith's
first studio album a legal Willie style
that's the idea for the music video was
less business and more personal two men
in black you better watch The Fresh
Prince told eg his then fiance Jada
Pinkett apparently did not believe he
could bust a move and this was a chance
to prove he had the good no one ever
truly knows everything about you you
know you can know someone your whole
life your parents don't really know
everything about you right you know so
just like that just a little something I
had to toss at miss pinky so she could
just see what the real flavor was you
know with this what the real Big Willy
is all about let me just
[Music]
I can't go no more that's what else
could I do I can't go the world the song
reached number one on the Billboard
airplay chart and even scored Smith a
Grammy for Best Rap solo performance I
like this life is good sorry
[Music]